hi kelly clarkson i am john t lee i'm a
chemistry and physics teacher at calvin
coolidge high school
in d.c public school district i teach in
the early college academy program
and that is when kids graduate they will
graduate with their
high school diploma and plus their
two-year associates degree from trinity
university all
in four years during this pandemic as
you can see
i turned my kitchen into a chemistry lab
our students are experiencing an
unprecedented amount of change
during this pandemic and i wanted when
they logged into
my online class classroom i wanted them
to see
something familiar and because when
students are in
a familiar environment they their
anxiety
decreases and their learning increases i
did this all for the love
and of my students and i want to say
kelly i absolutely love you
thank you for all that you do have a
great day bye bye
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going